[Music]
well ap is reporting a record 31 and a
half million americans plan to bet on
this year's super bowl according to
estimates released tuesday by the
gambling industries national trade group
they're so proud the game the american
gaming association forecasted over 7.6
billion dollars
will be wagered on pro football's
championship game set for sunday
both the amount of people planning to
bet up 35 last year and the estimated
amount of money being bet
get this
up 78
from last year
are new records
betters include people making casual
wagers with friends or relatives entries
into office pools wagers with licensed
sports books and bets placed with
illegal bookmakers americans have never
been more interested in legal sports
wagering said bill miller the
president's group and ceo of course he
would say that he's somewhat true that's
true by the way i think he's right when
the los angeles rams and cincinnati
bengals begin the game sunday evening in
the rams home stadium 30 states plus
washington d.c
will offer legal
gambling
i'm gonna be honest
give me a game of craps in vegas
and i'm like i and like there's a level
of entertainment there for me i just
have zero i don't understand the sports
gambling world
there's nothing entertaining
and like
i mean i guess there's like a social
aspect i just i genui i just don't i i i
don't know i just don't get it
okay
it says the girl who likes to play crap
i know but for me i'm like there's like
this there's this atmosphere there's so
i don't know something like about it but
when it just comes to sports gambling
i'm like i'm going to venmo money i'm
going to whatever it's just
there's nothing i don't i just don't
understand it so for me i don't you
don't get gambling period i don't bet
because i don't like to lose you're too
cheap yeah but the um
but i think what happens is i mean even
friends of mine they'll make a a
friendly wager not on money but on
something else like you have to wear the
wrong jersey the next day or something
like that it just makes you cheer for
your team that much more and i hate the
other team more or whatever yeah you
have the skin in the game in a sense
yeah but um you know it makes you pay
attention more it's not just so quote
it's not just uh casual viewing right
right uh and then of course the more you
put on it the more intense
uh you get there i suppose that that
would be the a reasonable theory by
someone who doesn't we're probably the
worst deal yeah we're the worst ones to
comment on this but what but what what
does occur to me is this is that you
know we have a student loan crisis in
america yeah
but we have 7.6 billion dollars being
bet on a football game i mean that's
insane
well well somebody's kids aren't going
to college right right you know and
there'll be people that lose their homes
over this there'll be people that that
are you know way over the edge i mean
they've lost their minds they're in a
gambling addiction mode
um and i don't know what the percentages
are but um it's a problem and so i don't
know what percentage of this is casual
ten dollar
and fifty or a hundred dollar betting
versus somebody betting a hundred
thousand or ten thousand that is you
know they're betting their 401k or
something on a football game well and
it's bizarre how much it's gone up
though i mean yeah
seventy eight percent about the amount
of money because you think through well
all you gotta do is watch if you've been
watching football you know it's the
sports betting's gone up because every
commercial is fanduel and caesar and i
see caesar one more time i'm gonna punch
the guy but uh it's a horrible
commercial but um
but the uh uh
the ads it's that but you know and if
they're dropping that kind of money in
that kind of venue on advertising that
means they're making it money so the
gambling industry is really good at
sucking you into gambling yep and uh
and you know
uh
the idea that you're betting money while
you're broke in debt your kids don't
have their college funded and you've got
a car payment uh
that makes you look pretty stupid yeah
it makes you look pretty stupid and so
that means there's a whole bunch of
people i'm listening to us right now i
just called them stupid
you know i really did and they are you
are if you're doing that well you're
putting yeah you're not stupid but your
activity is stupid this is a stupid idea
um it's like a stupid idea to go buy a
lotto ticket you know and now you you
probably got a better actual probability
of winning something here than you do
with lotto statistically speaking yeah
yeah but uh but
not based on the fact that you're the
bet world's best sports game because
you're because i mean i feel like our
stance your i'll just say my stance is
if you get to a point where you are
gambling there's such risk involved that
you have to be at a point it's almost to
me even like a bitcoin conversation like
if you are completely debt-free you have
your emergency fund you're funding your
retirement you're funding against
college and you have a little small
percentage of your world over here that
you kind of you're willing to lose
you're willing to lose it for the thrill
and it's there and that's where you're
choosing to kind of entertain then you
know what i mean at that point it's kind
of like some people buy a boat
some people buy
whatever for for recreation and this is
recreational sure
gaming at that point but yeah the amount
of money in the amount of people 31 31.5
million americans are betting that's
like everybody it's just a lot
it's a lot of you guys so where billion
dollars
is wagered
that's i wonder why to the money so
people people are willing to spend more
right now in life anything i feel like
whether it's houses or cars or travel or
food like people are adjustable
inflation too but like people are just
spending more
and there's still this this effect of
the pandemic i swear the 2020 you're all
cooped up 2021 you're still kind of
walking on eggshells but you're getting
there and it's almost like we hit 2022
and it's just like everyone's just
screaming for normalcy again and it's
like all the pent up tension still is is
being
released
in life and part of it and i'm like i
just wonder if that's part of it too
like the amount of the 78
more being better than last year
that's so that's crazy yeah so i don't
know it's a it's a huge increase part of
this though is the marketing and the
advertising is driving it because
they're talking people into betting yeah
that never would have thought of it
before second thing is there's a real
get-rich-quick vibe going on in america
right now yeah that's fair yeah this is
a sense of
a shortcut i'm looking for a shortcut
i'm looking for a shortcut i'm looking
for an easy money and uh and you know
the ultimate in arrogance is thinking
you're gonna win you know that you've
got something figured out you've got an
edge you've figured out the pattern
you've figured out how this is going to
work yeah and that's just so laughable
yeah that um you know i played the odds
and i won the last five games and so now
i'm going to double down you know yeah
that's just laughable that's that's but
but um
the the sad thing is is in the wake of
this there's two things two types of
people playing ones that are gonna lose
everything
um and i don't know what percentage that
is but we all know they're there
um and with that kind of increase you're
going to see an increase in that uh
ratio wise perception wise
the next thing you're going to run into
is that that that's a lot more is that
basically you have a lot of people who
really don't have money to lose that are
going to lose it
meaning you lose 500 bucks and you've
got a car payment you don't have that
money to lose yeah you lose 500 bucks
and you're still sitting with a student
loan or your kid's student loan is or
you're kid student college loan college
fund is not funded then you know you
don't have money to lose
and you know you're gambling away your
family's
good the prosperity of your family then
and that's you don't have that much and
we know a large percentage of these
people even casual bettors yeah fall
into that
and so
um
you know it's just uh there's some
devastating numbers that that come out
of this it's just the ripple effect of
it i think the first time i saw this big
time was when i was following the
bankruptcy statistics so closely
um this was 20 years ago the number one
county for bankruptcy filing in the
united states at that time
was
shelby county memphis tennessee
and what happened was and it had just
erupted it just become that it was the
number four county or number five county
before that and it had become that but
it was tied to the fact that tunica is
just south of there and the casinos had
been put into tunica
and uh a lot of uh lower income people
out of memphis were traveling down to
tunica and losing what they didn't even
have to lose
and so that's true and lotto gets placed
into
lotto as well yeah yeah
we saw this direct correlation between
the casino the lower socio-economic
demographic and now a bankruptcy
statistic that is number one in the
nation and this is the kind of stuff
it's a pain statistic
and that's what you're going to see
around this it's just sad